the concept of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
and regarding the concept of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala the best reply that
any Muslim can give you the shortest and
the best and the most concise definition
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala is given in
the glorious Quran by Allah himself in
surahlas chapter number 112 verse number
1 to4 where Allah
says say He is Allah one and only.
Allah Allah the absolute and
eternal. He begget not nor is he
begotten. There's nothing like him. This
is a four-line definition of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala given in the
glorious Quran. Any person says so and
so candidate is God. And if that
candidate fits in this four-line
definition, we Muslims have no objection
in accepting that candidate as God.
First
is say Allah one and only. Second is
Allah Allah the absolute and eternal.
Third
is he begget not nor is he
begotten. And the fourth is the most
stringent. There is nothing like him.
The moment you can compare God to
anything in this world, he's not
God. This suras is the touchstone of
theology. Theo means God, logic mean
study, theology mean study of God.
Touchstone as many of you will be aware
that if you want to buy or sell jewelry,
gold jewelry, and you want to know how
pure is the gold, so you take it to a
goldsmith. He takes this touch stone and
he rubs the jewelry against the
touchstone and observes the color and
tells you that this is 24 karat gold or
he may tell you it is 22 karat gold or
he may say it is 18 karat gold or he may
say it is not gold at all because
everything that glitters is not gold. So
surahlas is the touchstone of theology.
If any human being says that so and so
person is God or so and so candidate is
God. If it fits in this definition of
suras we Muslims have no objection in
accepting that candidate as God. Let me
give an example that there
are some human beings who consider
Bhagwan Rajnish to be God. You may have
heard the name of Bhagwan Rajnes. He was
very famous. He was from India from the
country where I come. So there are some
human beings who think he's God. So let
us put this Bhagwan Rajnes to the test
of
suras. The first
is say Allah one and only. Was Bhagwan
Rajnish the only man who claimed
divinity? We have thousands of them and
many from the country where I come
India. He's not the only one. The second
test Allah Allah the absolute and
eternal was raish absolute and eternal.
When we read his autobiography we come
to know he was suffering from astama
from diabetes malitis from chronic
backachche. Imagine almighty god
suffering from aama from diabetes
malitis from chronic backachche. Third
test, he begget not nor is he begotten.
We know from his biography that Rajnes
had a mother and a father. He was born
in Jabalpur, Mhyra Pradesh. And later on
in 1981 he goes to America and in a
village by the name of
Oregon he starts his own village called
as Rajnish Puram and he takes thousands
of American for a ride. Later on the
American government arrest him and puts
him behind bars. Rajnes claims that the
American government gave me slow
poisoning. Imagine almighty God being
slow poisoned. In
1985 they kick Rajnesh out of the
country US and he comes back to India
and in the state of Maharashtra in the
city of Punea he starts his new center
there Oshoku commamune and if you go
there it is mentioned on samadhi.
Samadis when the Hindus when they when
they burn when they cremate the body
nash are kept there and on the stone
it's mentioned oh show the dashnish
never born never died but visited the
earth from the 11th of December 1931 to
the 19th of January 1990 never born
never died but visited the earth from
the 11th of December 1931 to the 19th of
January 1990. They forgot to mention on
the samadi he was not given visas to 21
different countries of the world.
Imagine almighty god coming in this
world to visit the world and he requires
visas and the archbishop of Greece said
if you don't remove rashes from this
country we will burn his house and the
house of his disciple and the last
test there's nothing like him is so
stringent that no one besides Allah can
pass the moment you can compare Allah to
anyone in this world he's not God.